Philip do you know uh your your present
came today yes did you know it was a box
of pears I said yeah you like them yeah
they're very nice but how many pears can
I eat
I'm like well give some to Dad well your
dad maybe he's gonna eat one or two
pairs there's like 12 pairs here
I said well
I hope you like them because another box
of is coming next month she said what
more pairs and I said so a different box
every month is that every month what did
you get us in some kind of cult
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola with me
that dry cleaner by Keith Phelps
new sport Sports
you know George is oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Lopez George Lopez oh my God omg
omg
oh my God
support for today's episode comes from
True classic they have the absolute best
fitting t-shirts man can buy finding the
right T-shirt with a little bit of dad
bod is incredibly frustrating most
t-shirts are either way too tight on
your gut or look too big and and boxy
you're not in high school anymore and
it's time to upgrade so it's funny that
that true classic is a sponsored because
today
I bought a t-shirt in my dressing room
there at Warner Brothers NBC you know as
I star in my own show again
and when I opened the bag of the shirt
the immediate feel of the shirt
resonated with me because I mean I'm in
Chicago We're All About t-shirts and I
said wow this is and it was a true
classic t-shirt so I will say that
upgrade your wardrobe with true classic
get 25 off of trueclassic.com with code
OMG hi free shipping included on
purchases over a hundred dollars so I
mean that's that's easy I mean these are
great shirt to wear them again and again
the more they get broken in this was a
v-neck you got crew neck and maybe a
turtle that hide your hickeys from your
old lady 100 risk-free guarantee with a
30-day return policy remember when used
to go Las Vegas and your girlfriend will
give you a hickey so that nobody else
will find you attractive Stay classy
with true classic your dad bod well
thank you
okay I I've always been a believer in uh
paranormal Spirits or whatever it goes I
mean maybe I saw him as a kid maybe I
didn't recognize him but I always felt
something so uh
explain to me your experiences with Momo
Rodriguez and his uh paragordo uh shows
well I I've been to his shows I follow
Momo and his paranormal Gordo shows are
good I did his podcast with him and no
but what what has happened that that I
mean well you know he's trying to get me
involved he asked me at first if I
believed in Aliens and I said no because
I don't look up you know I don't give a
[ __ ] what's up there I'm down on the
ground you know and you believe in your
vergas and you can't see it exactly it's
still there it's a homie it's it's there
you told me it was [ __ ] you said hey
yo you believe in the stuff I don't
believe in that [ __ ] you don't
believe it I don't I don't believe in
the the alien [ __ ] uh your parents have
you ever felt the the presence of your
parents around you
I have I have you know when I got my
bachelor's degree uh somebody asked me
what'd you do you looked up and you know
I this is for them you know when I got
my bachelor's a couple of weeks ago I
got honored at a Galaxy game
and uh explain to us what that is uh
Galley Galaxy the the Galaxy uh
professional soccer team right here in
Los Angeles I was uh contacted by them
and asked if I would be willing to
accept an award they want to give me
they called it uh the
match uh hero of the match award and so
it was amazing I don't know my name had
been submitted and due to my what I did
in combat and what I did with 38 years
in law enforcement coupled with the
Night Stalker the documentary everything
that was done they're asking me if I'd
be willing to accept the award let me
answer your question yes sir of all the
things that you've done
which is the one that stays in your head
more the the fact that you made it
through Vietnam
or you were detective because listen I
mean
I personally
in 79 when Iran had the hostages
there's a documentary on uh HBO Max
I had to go reg I was the last one of my
friends to go and register at the post
office we all had to register
and I I just couldn't imagine going to
war
uh and you went to war and were in at
War and came back yes if there's
anything that occupies your mind more
than that
do you have you left that in behind I I
left it behind but not my friends I
still meet with my friends try to meet
every couple of years reunions together
uh we do that send pictures we exchange
messages we talk on the phone uh there's
some there it's like the abandoned
brothers and it's always an emotional
thing it is it's very emotional right
when you're with those guys do you sense
the presence of the guys that were with
you that yes absolutely it's a it's a
fine group of men
uh
uh I mean they're they're special they
are they are very they're they're very
special and you know people people that
um
uh
I mean people respect the stock market
and it's nothing it's money but when you
respect
the lives of the families of the
soldiers everybody that has to go
through what it's like to have someone
come back or have someone not come back
it's not ever [ __ ] easy without
Fortune without Fame without degrees
with nothing these are guys who are
willing to give up their life for you
for me we were brothers some got injured
some made it back some did something
those that made it back we appreciate
each other but we appreciate we haven't
lost the appreciation for those that
didn't make it it's a real thing man
it's a real thing and this country
doesn't respect
veterans the way that they should
and
I understand why I saw a guy being real
wheelchair through the airport and he
was wearing a hat he was in the Navy and
you know what I would say I used to say
why is this dude wearing a hat of that
of his thing but you know what it's
[ __ ] Pride it's the acknowledgment
and and everybody that sees anyone
that's wearing a [ __ ] hat from
whatever Brigade whatever part of Paris
whatever they were part of you should go
up there and you should thank them for
their service and that's all you have to
say or if you say sir thank you for your
service
and let it be that it you know uh when I
go to the Lord as you call the VHS when
I go to the VFW with my friends you know
I wear a half place open oh yeah we're
back in business brother oh no [ __ ] what
happened did that person help you the
guy that was going to help you throw
some [ __ ] everybody everybody got it
back together we're back to drinking
wine everything's going good so over
there the guys wear their stuff to show
that you know hey we're all vets but
aside from that uh there's only a couple
of t-shirts that I have that I wear uh I
acknowledge because they don't because
they're the only ones that fit her
because
I want to get to the root of it oh no I
buy I buy big ones now so will you were
you were you were you uh um I was much
thinner were you sad when uh Zachary all
closed because they had 8X
[Laughter]
one time Momo was standing still and so
they came into a [ __ ] fumigator
though man
they told me it couldn't move for four
hours
it's all good
that's like a [ __ ] possible Memorial
Day veterans day big days for me they're
big days for my family they know that I
appreciate when we came back from
Operation Desert Storm uh my wife well
they were over there my wife went to
every house on the Block and put yellow
ribbons around the trees they know it's
important does it does it ever catch you
like in the morning or at night or when
you're by yourself in the car no there's
a great movie out there's a great uh
yeah it's a movie right now
it's better than deep throat
I don't think there's one better than
deep throat there's a movie out right
now the the greatest beer run or
something like that oh yeah oh yeah it's
based on a true story I saw the
documentary about a year or two ago and
it's an excellent movie about guys from
New York went to Vietnam and one of
their buddies bought a bunch of beer and
went over there as a civilian got a ride
on a Merchant Marine chair and delivered
beer to his friends in in Vietnam that's
a true story it's a true story and it's
an excellent movie it because it gives
you the view of somebody that's very
patriotic that is doing something for
his brothers that are over there
fighting and he goes over there and by
the time he comes back he's realizing
that
the same thing that I've said you know
there are no winners in war you do what
you got to do because you think it's
right and they talk about
guys like me 18 years old they tell us
what to do we go out and we do it we
think we're doing the right thing and
then we come back here and we treat it
like [ __ ] but it shows you both sides
and it's a I highly recommend it you
gotta watch it it's a good movie
um
um you know
oh there's a lot there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of cemeteries in in the
United States yes
um and almost been to many of them
looking for paranormals you're looking
for [ __ ] pan
I saw I saw a homeless lady with some
big ass stethos I've been trying to find
her
I should have pulled over when I saw it
it was just they were [ __ ] hanging
down like way down but just a little bit
of a [ __ ] like a little bit of a
tortilla right
so
but when you when you see a um
when you see a a military cemetery
because it's the same
uh headstone yeah
um
there's I mean they're just rows of of
people
um anyone that would have evaded uh War
do you ever think they have a second
thought about what they did
I don't know about those people that
went they got to live on their own yeah
they live in right I don't care about
them I don't even get emotional when I
drive by military cemeteries because
they weren't with me yeah right you know
they weren't with me over there and I
don't know that so it's just part of
life I'm just grateful you know and and
when I came on the sheriff's department
or Homicide Bureau these guys are
brothers just like those over there if
somebody wears a a
a fatigue uh pants
do you look at it as an insult no not at
all I don't care what do you wear
I don't care where you were out of here
no more words I mean if I were it but
Momo was the same shirt because you have
to find
no way
so many people where so many people wear
fatigue pants now whether they were in
the military or not so I don't care in a
sense in a sense I don't question I have
military uh pants that but then I would
say in Aaron don't you think it's a
little bit insulting
if you're a [ __ ] Dodger you know and
you see somebody wearing a jersey you go
all right they're supporting the team
you don't since we don't support the
military
it's a I would find it a bit of a
[ __ ] because there's so many uh
veterans that are mistreated I find it a
bit of a [ __ ] slap in the face to
tell you the truth to me honestly
there's so many other problems that I
got you know I can't worry about all of
it so I just worry about stuff that
affects myself my friends my family
that's why you don't believe in ghosts I
don't that's why I don't believe in
ghosts but he sense the presence of it
well because I think you you uh you seen
so Much Death in your life and you've
experienced stories of death and how
people died or killed so I think
worrying about a ghost is the last thing
you want to think about I've never had
bad ghost coming I I've dreamed about I
woke my wife up at four in the morning
one time
and I said hey this is real [ __ ] one of
my partners Joe Parra yeah I mean he had
passed away
and all of a sudden in my dream he's in
my dream and he he comes back into my
dream he says hey he called me on the
phone he says Gil I want you to meet me
across the street I said what the [ __ ]
you made me cross street you're dead he
says just meet me across the [ __ ]
Street wow so I go across the street and
meet him he's sitting on the bus okay
nobody knows this I'm back here they're
bringing my son his son
I should I'll say it his son who is now
chief of police for Huntington Park
Police Department not not in Huntington
Beach Police Department I watch this kid
growing up as there's a whole big
difference between us
he retired from our department he was on
our department we'll watch him pull
through the ranks so he says I'm here
they're allowing me to see my son today
and his son was formerly a SWAT team
member so I he says don't say anything
nobody knows about this just be cool
what did he look like did he look like
the best he ever looked before Oh you
look good he looked looked happy look
clear look resolved very usually when
they look their best it's a visitation
that there's no doubt that's why I woke
up my wife because he said this and he
said why because you're [ __ ] my
morning you can't do anything without
her no and he says get here wake up
bring your wife let her know so they
said that the [ __ ] the ghost didn't
wake up your wife he knows you you're
not only am I mode in this world you're
about my morning
he wanted to visit
he says okay I gotta go now so here
comes the guys from Seb he was in his
dream right yes he was not he was not
awake no no I'm in my dream well so here
come the guys from SCB SWAT team they
form a line and here comes Eric they're
allowing Eric to visit his dad and they
said Gill you can't come in yet and they
take him into this building yeah he goes
into the building as a private meeting
and then they come in and they said Gil
you can come on in now so that was an
astro dream they call him Astro astral
projection but it's a it was an ass you
were having you're having a vivid one
he was coming into his dream and he was
bringing you in his support well now I
we go inside this room and there's a
bunch of people and everybody in there
although they look good yeah they're all
dead they all look good usually his
mother his father other people yes they
were all there they were walking around
I was like did you recognize all these
people yes was there some people that
you did not recognize yes one a female
okay comes up to me and she's talking
and she's a good looking female she's
talking to me and it's very friendly
very nice and I go up to Gill I said hey
Gail who was that she remembers yeah I
don't know who she is he says you don't
remember because she was one of your
victims
she was somebody that I had handled as a
murderer and now I did good she's she's
now dead there's a there's a book called
The Five People You Meet in Heaven and
then that book it says that once
somebody that you've touched or you've
resolved their unfinished business comes
back kind of to help you like a spirit
guide oh now the thing is we don't
usually scientists say we cannot see
people in our dreams we've never ever
met before we cannot come up with that
visualization of a person so when you
see someone you've never seen they say
those are visitations from either Angels
or loved ones that are attached to our
connected to you I hope she was an angel
she she visited she talked to me he says
you don't remember her
she was one of your friends the guy told
you she was one of your victims Gil told
me she was one of my records and amen
then
have time visitation yeah
okay now it's time for them for leave
the bus is outside all these they're all
walking out and I said Gil this is good
just tell everybody I'm okay oh my God
and the dream is over with he goes away
I it was so vivid
I woke up my wife and I said I gotta
tell you about this right now now I told
his son I waited till the morning and I
called I said Eric I gotta tell you this
and Eric is just like his dad that
caustic piece of [ __ ]
he's going to hear this eventually Chief
of Police from Huntington Beach I call
him on I tell Eric I gotta share this
with you this is about your dad
and he believed that he says kill he
says that's crazy thank you for sharing
it with me
he says but I think maybe now you can go
back to dreaming about women because
you're dreaming about my dad that makes
you gay and just slam me slam the door
I'm like what's the biggest fear it's
the biggest fear he was he was slamming
me because I'm instead of dreaming about
naked women I'm dreaming about his dad I
remember you laughed at it I freaking
out I think with your conditions that
you have you probably dreaming about
[ __ ] doctors
I do so so how how long is this dream
that he had
well in life and when he's sleeping yeah
it could be a second now we for us we
think as time as you know there's a
timeline on the other side in the dream
sequence and that parallel universe
there's no time that's why people say
well my loved one's gonna be don't they
miss me since they're dead okay for them
it's instant we're the ones that suffer
down here but for them time does not
exist yeah it was you know they know
they're not alive anymore they know
they're not alive it's an extremely yeah
extremely Vivid dream for me
don't ever apologize man
um uh I brought Momo Rodriguez in he's a
comedian and he's very funny also I
think you guys know each other uh no but
I stalk him on Instagram I've gone to
his events and like kind of this is this
is the guy like I I love I mean you know
we worked close to each other there at
Warner Brothers
um but also the food aspect of of what
you've brought you've managed to do food
in a sense that people bring
heart and soul to it Phil
listen if you work on a TV show right
like this yes one of the great ways of
showing people that you care about them
and even love them
is great food uh backstage right yes
craft service that's right
you know I once worked on a show it was
a hit sitcom I was working for somebody
else and a memo went around the office
and this is what the memo said
we noticed some of you are coming in in
the morning and putting milk on your
cereal
the milk is for Coffee the cereal is for
snacks
we do not provide breakfast for you
please do not put milk on your cereal
this was a hit show
and I read this and my jaw dropped at
the I said if I'm ever lucky enough to
have my own show we're gonna have milk
on a series oh man that's how and that
was before milk became
um
two percent skim milk there was skim
milk there was now it's almond milk tree
soy that was pre-almond that was
pre-coconut that was pretty okay now now
I got anything as a uh quote-unquote
foodie
um yeah what are your restrictions let's
start with that
well you know I'm not seeking out the
weird stuff I'm not like Andrew Zimmern
who
makes a career of eating weird stuff
yeah do you guys like to eat the weird
stuff I I do I haven't I found it I
haven't deterred I haven't turned away
too much food um when I had my talk show
Zac Efron was eating uh chocolate
covered scorpions and uh oh I could not
I could not do it
did he like it he did like it
he did like a baby scorpion I I could
you could you do that no that's not it's
not food you know I might take a tiny I
I've if you've seen somebody feed Phil I
have to try certain things because I
want to be polite you know in Mexico
like in Oaxaca there's there's salad
with some little worms in it there's
there's
um
and the worms and ant eggs to eat the
chicatanas right and there's uh crickets
and even bigger grasshoppers
and I've tasted these things it's not
something I seek out because you know
I'm just a white boy from from from New
York so I I'm not used to that but I'll
try it and I gotta be honest it's not
bad wow you just got to get it once you
get your head around it look look at all
these people this entire culture
not only eats it they like it
they do like it
um yeah growing up in New York
what was your entree into TV
oh my God you know I'm I'm pretty old
now but but yes I know but but no no and
so am I but but but was it was it in in
your in your family were there people
that were in TV or were they production
no no no my dad was super funny he was
really funny you know he was he was like
from this old Jewish tradition of of you
ever hear of the Catskills
right he would go up there and he would
you know
fool around on the mic at the hotel you
know be like an emcee but but not not
professional but he was super funny
right and my mom I think was attracted
to him because he was so funny and I
realized that that was like the way to
get attention in the house I bet you
have a similar story that that the way
to get stay up late maybe or or just to
gain favor and love even from your
parents was make them laugh
so that's how it happened you know I and
I mean let's say Phil you know like on a
Saturday or a Sunday outside in the
front yard all you know our parents were
live I was raised my grandparents and
they're out there and they're watering
and everybody's laughing you might be
doing something that makes them laugh
and it just seems like everything is
right in the world at that time your
parents are alive all your friends are
together you know you haven't lost
anyone yet I mean it's just an
incredible incredible time
but here's the problem George we don't
realize it when it's happened
you only realize it after yes that's
right we look back on it now and boy we
wish we could go back that's right maybe
we would cherish those moments more
right if we had them back again there's
a famous play called our town and that's
what it's about we don't realize how
wonderful life is while we're living it
right I feel my favorite part was that
was uh whenever your dad would tell a
joke in every show
yes and just the way he would just go
back and forth with you about where you
visited and what you've eaten but those
Mexico episodes man that really opened
up my heart how you went heart person to
Mexico that means a lot to me to my my
mom my dad I mean it was to see you and
and the streets of pepito eating heart
and random organs was just like I did it
but you know what I could not love
Mexico more every time I go I fall in
love with it more and more I mean the
Mexico City
show that we did I can't wait to go back
there we did the Oaxaca show this past
season you guys have been to Oaxaca yes
isn't it the greatest the most colorful
beautiful place with the most beautiful
people in the food is I mean it's killer
it's so great I heard you're into Mezcal
now more though yes tequila oh
I like them both how did you uh will you
explain to uh explain to me
uh the differences between Mezcal and
tequila
it's very simple Mezcal is smoked
underground and all all of all of
tequila is mezcal coming from the agave
plant sure but the treatment of it makes
it without the smoke in the steel uh
kettles
that's what makes it tequila but all
Agave Spirits are mezca
and in Mexico is there going to be a
shortage because of the time that it
takes to grow Agave is there going to be
a shortage of tequila there might be you
know what people are telling me also is
they speed up the process
because it takes six years for the agave
plant to to be ready to to be turned
into domestic tequila
and what they do is they cheat and some
of the best selling Spirits out there
have additives in them to make them
taste better so when you say oh this one
oh you can taste like vanilla and honey
no do you know why because they put
official honey and vanilla in the things
maybe do that with almonds well you know
we just we just had one I went to Cabo
last weekend and we had one that the guy
says oh this is Rose and you're like oh
Rose tequila with rose that had a little
bit of a uh
right yeah so that's the way I heard
they do that I heard they do that in
wine as well the wines that we love from
the Napa Valley you know they have these
beautiful oh it's so fruit forward they
say you know this one is so Jammy they
use all these words that's because
they're adding crap in there but I mean
it says a lot to
where we are is a world where we
couldn't wait for something to to be
right
you had to speed it up makes the world
go round well uh I think the peanut
allergies are become I think the nut
because they created a seed that was not
a real peanut seed that Monsanto
whatever whatever they're doing is it's
there they have to create more chickens
in a short amount of time that's to
create more corn in a short amount of
time we don't have the luxury of waiting
for an agave plant to be six years you
start to add additives and now you're
changing the whole flavor
okay listen you know what the worst
example of that is beef
yeah so so we when we were growing up
the cows ate grass when a cow eats grass
the meat from that cow is actually good
for you it actually lowers your bad
cholesterol and raises your good
cholesterol when you eat a grass-fed
beef
but a cow will get much fatter faster if
it eats corn and grain
and it then gets sick because they're
not supposed to eat that and then
they're treated with antibodies and
guess who eats those antibodies that
those those medicines we do and then we
get sick that's right
that's right
fed people I want to go eat with food
that's what you want
and and uh at some point so so the idea
of um uh feed Phil how did that come
about because because I mean you were
behind
behind the camera of yeah
some people say well you should stay
behind no no maybe we shouldn't see you
so much but but I mean I I I was you
know listen I made Everybody Loves
Raymond and in the nine years that
Raymond was on the business really
changed so I'm talking about from
uh 1996-2005.
and by the time that show was over
the networks didn't really want that
kind of show and I just went about my
business trying to create more shows and
no one was taking them man and so after
a while I thought
okay I'm banging my head against this
wall of Show Business what if I picked a
spot on the wall
that is different but I would really
like it so that's food and travel and I
had this idea and I went into first PBS
and I said
I'm exactly like Anthony Bourdain if he
was afraid of everything
and they like that it took me about 10
years to get to that point 10 years
after Raymond wow PBS gave me six
episodes on the air we did very well but
then they couldn't afford to do the show
anymore and here came Netflix went to
Netflix changed the title to somebody
feed Phil and now we're going into our
sixth season which starts on uh Tuesday
the 18th I'm good for you incredible
thank you it's a great thank you so
happy and the wonderful thing about
luckiest guy you'll ever see and the
wonderful thing about somebody feed Phil
is you can catch it in whatever season
and you haven't seen it you can go back
and binge watch it and it's as good as
anything that's on Netflix because I
mean the idea that you bring is you're
such a unique incredible personality and
the fact that maybe these things are
natural to you which I love because
you're you're a Jewish kid from New York
and you just open yourself up yeah to
the world and like you said I'll I you
gotta try it you gotta try it you've got
to try it I think the world would be
better if we all could experience a
little bit of other people's experiences
so I implore everyone through the show
to travel right and I'm just using food
in my stupid sense of humor and the
things that have you've done in the show
what's made it back into your house like
what are the things that's a great
question that you bring back
you know there's always a dish somewhere
where I go oh my God I gotta I gotta
find this in L.A like I was in I was in
Thailand I was in a little place in
Thailand called Chiang Mai in the north
of Thailand have you guys ever had a
dish called cow soy
no not me cow soy is a coconut curry
broth with hand pulled noodles like the
best pasta ever had and then there's all
these like chilies and pickled mustard
greens and onions and scallions and then
whatever meat or protein that you want
in there shrimp beef pork chicken
whatever you want tofu even if you want
to go veggie and then crispy noodles on
top this is one of the most delicious
things I ever ate and it costs a dollar
[Laughter]
put it in a tortilla I don't I'm not
kidding you George the moment I ate that
I pulled out my phone and I looked for
cow soy Los Angeles where am I going to
find this dish in Los Angeles guess what
we have more Thai restaurants than any
other city in America right here and
there are plenty of places that have cow
soy I didn't know to ask for it wow now
I do now you do that's a trip right you
taught me about Mexican food man and I'm
Mexican no and I was you know born
non-stop tacos my whole life and you
introduced me to a place that's named
after not after me but my name uh Momo
so I one day I go I take George a bunch
of tacos to his house
then he got mad because I I took most of
them home no he did this dude like left
me like two man I said yeah bring them
to my house he brought me like two I'm
like who the [ __ ] brings two tacos to
somebody's house
um who recommended who who ended who
recommended these places to you
I have experts right I have people who
who uh really know their stuff so I ask
them but also I think it goes to I would
say that you know
growing up uh Latino or however Jewish
however when my grandmother was the cook
and my grandmother
would take a bit of this and throw it in
there and and she lived she had her own
way and that's different than the way
that everybody else's mom or grandmother
would make food and I think that is the
cartilage in the in the body of of food
is that it can't be measured the great
The Great Food cannot be measured can't
be weighed
a great Point like your grandma
made the food a certain way and let's
take a dish that you guys both know that
your grandmother's made
which one is more authentic
you can't judge it no there's no way you
can the word authentic is overused yep
what makes your grandmother more
authentic than his grandma I think
authentic is almost in the sense of a
basic it's basic in a way because
authentic is not it doesn't have a life
authentic is that's authentic beer but
okay what but what what is had what has
it done to become authentic so authentic
we've outgrown I think the term
authentic in food yes I agree do you
know what the only word that matters is
delicious exactly exactly I think you
told me about one day I told you Phil I
was like what's your favorite stuff and
you said whatever tastes good
um you know yeah that's the bottom line
is it does it taste good
in one bite or or sometimes does it
takes good in the third fifth bite
that's a great question
I think when something is undeniable
delicious you you kind of know
immediately like boom it hits you but
there are other dishes where you're kind
of eating it maybe you're a little
distracted
you know you're talking to your friends
you're having a drink and without
realizing it you've been doing this a
hell of a lot yeah you've been shoveling
it in and then at five ten minutes later
you go what is with this that I cannot
stop right what is going on
you you made a sandwich you took
sandwiches onto a late night show and it
was you said it was pigs pork there was
something in there with uh one of the
late nights it was pig fat pig fat
yes yes that's the show I was talking
about now is that I I wanted to find out
more about this how larda was it raw was
it cooked no it is cooked but it is it
is
it is so good if you if you put it on
the pan it'll liquefy like fat okay I
mean it's it's a it's so beautiful and
it's clean it's not like you know we
think of fat as being ooh you can't eat
that donut it's just some you know how
when you have great bacon you have to
widen the yes and the and the brown the
the white can sometimes if it's great
bacon be just as good right exactly
that's right
where's it derived from
Pig
okay where can we get do they make those
on the West Coast and where do we find a
Petco
I feel I think at Petco they have it
there's a lot does it what's the tape
have you had it no I want to find out
because I wanted it
like oh [ __ ] yes it looked good but is
that he feel when you saw Lardo were you
afraid or you were like what's the
Jewish then the Jews that have like uh
chicken fat they put at tables
absolutely yeah we're not afraid of fat
yeah I mean some some religious Jewish
people who keep kosher they're not going
to eat pork at all so it doesn't matter
if it's fat or not fat they're not
eating that but
um I didn't grow up very religious I'm
not Kosher and uh man I got to be honest
I love pork
then we go to when we go to dinner and
there's all kinds of dishes on the table
you know we say pork wins
but you know like in Malcolm X with uh
uh Spike Lee said man I can't be a
Muslim I love white women and pigs feet
too much too that's right that's fine
but but and when you were growing up
um your friends you've had to have some
friends that were kosher of course and
they couldn't come and eat at your house
well they could as long as we didn't
serve that oh yeah yeah I mean but it's
you know and when someone's kosher if
you're playing literally when you're
playing football or basketball at the
park I mean everything has to you know
all of a sudden now you're looking and
you're saying okay well can I eat that
can I have this listen we have bacon and
eggs every weekend right yes but and so
that when you're a little kid you know
baking your favorite thing and if my
grandmother came over
you know old school religious yep you
couldn't even say the word bacon eggs
for breakfast did your grandmother used
to uh somebody told me you know I was
trying to make a I was trying to do a
show that I sold it but I didn't have
nothing to do it where my my mom or my
grandmother makes the best and it was
whatever and then somebody's telling me
about gefilter fish where they would
have it in the bathtub or they would
take like a a stick and they'd go in
there and just like when it was time to
cook the grandmother would the filter
fish would be in the tub
until it was time to to use it and then
go in there and close the club it and
take it to the kitchen
you're talking about
the old country yes you're Tucker you're
talking about Poland or Lithuania
that's not happening in the Bronx
they go in their [ __ ] like a billy
club
yeah yeah yeah the old country you know
uh we were doing a show Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar was uh on the show and he's
Muslim and then we started to take a an
order and he ordered some rice and then
we ordered some some but
the beef fried rice got
cooked on the same Grill
as his rice
yeah and I was sitting there next to him
and he got up and he stood up and he
went
to the back he vomited uh what he was
eating because he hadn't had uh pork in
so long
oh boy just the fact and he knew he
called the place they called the place
and said did you guys cross things they
said yes
they didn't know they were making it for
him but it wasn't from the idea that he
literally got physically
tasting it yes
about Kareem but if you're not used to
something I mean you ask me all the time
they asked me if I got food poisoning in
all my travels you know going to Bangkok
and Saigon and all around the world
eating at the night markets you know
where they I see Scorpions on a stick
and all kinds of stuff and I swear to
God I never got food poisoning once
except for
one time
San Francisco
well it's okay San Francisco and what
was that what was that what kind of food
was it
you know don't know because I ate a lot
that day but it could have been a combo
platter but you know just the numbers
[Music]
when when I was in 10th Grade
um our baseball coach was gone for like
10 days and they said oh yes food
poisoning and when he came back he was
physically he looked like he had lost 30
pounds and he was saying he was vomiting
and he said to us and this has been true
to the times he who says if you ever
have for food poisoning and while you're
vomiting whatever comes into your head
is the thing that made you sick
that's funny I always thought
that whatever you throw up from even as
a little kid you never want that food
again
yeah the times that I've he had
mayonnaise he had mayonnaise that was
laid out that was bad and I've had a
couple things that were bad and while
you were vomiting I said it's got to be
this thing and and you know what that he
told me that in
1977 and to this day it's been true the
the very the few times that I've gotten
sick what am I downfall I never threw up
as a kid so I Hate Everything wow
growing up so much I've only done it uh
maybe four times in my life I can't
stand it's the worst thing we have a
saying when it's coming out both ends we
call it
and uh
um so so how were you introduced to uh
Ray Romano
oh uh he was a stand-up com uh comedian
and he did he did Letterman right and
then wore white pants
that's exactly right he worked for he
was working for 12 years before he got
on Letterman and from six minutes on
Letterman Letterman said there should be
a show for this guy and they started
looking for writers to create a show for
Rhett and so we met and he told me about
his Italian family and for every crazy
story he had about his Italian family I
had one about my Jewish Family it turns
out we're not so different right and uh
I don't know that's how it happened and
and and uh did you pitch it to other
networks other than CBS nope because
Letterman's deal was with CBS right and
uh
uh they they like Ray and they like my
spiritual picture so that was it was it
Les moonves
that's right and what was the pilot of
Everybody Loves Raymond
the pilot was very simple it was uh and
and I at first you wanna the first idea
is making a show where that's kind of
sets up why they're there and everything
this kind of they call it the premise
pilot why did Rey move across the street
from his parents right that's that's
kind of what I was thinking would be the
pilot and they said we don't want the
premise pilot because the premise pilot
is unique that story will only be once
right they want a more typical episode
so forget that
and think of a typical episode we want
to kind of start in the middle now
that's harder because you're in the
middle but you still have to introduce
all the characters right so I needed a
simple story The Simple Story was it's
Deborah's birthday and she tells Raymond
I don't want your parents coming over
for my birthday but I have one evening
where they don't come over that's it
that was the whole premise and I had Ray
go over there and try to tell his
parents why they wouldn't be around so
they can't come over and he lies to them
and they they and and I showed I wanted
to show the audience [ __ ] just how
crazy Rey's parents are and how tough
they're gonna be to deal with them so I
took a story from my own personal life
which was this I gave my parents the
fruit of the month club in real life do
you guys know did you ever have yeah
somebody used to send me that somebody
gave it to me
well I got a phone call from my mother
Philip do you know uh your your present
came today yes did you know it was a box
of pears I said yeah you like them yeah
they're very nice but how many pears can
I eat
I'm like well give some to Dad whoa your
dad maybe he's gonna eat one or two
pairs there's like 12 pairs here
I said well
I hope you like them because another box
of is coming next month she said what
more pairs and I said so a different box
every month is that every month what did
you get us in some kind of cult
she thought she thought it was like a
box of heads from a murderer she said I
can't talk anymore there's too much
and I put that scene in the pilot it's a
[ __ ] funny man and that's the scene
that got us on the air oh my God so it
just shows you you gotta write it's
what's real to you I'm unique to you
I'll get as specific as you can because
it's really that specificity that
becomes Universe when you were looking
to hire the writers what what kind of
room were you trying to put together
funny
yeah so so that's it and and that's it I
hired a lot of comics I did I knew Rey
would be comfortable with comics and I
knew that I could teach the structure of
the sitcom that's the teachable part you
can't teach funny
no
you know
um
one time uh you know Doris got arrest
her soul love her yes she was doing
these benefits over there at the Saban I
think it's a Saban now it used to be
like right and she asked me to be a part
of it so I got so I'm on stage four you
guys on stage five and I get a note and
it says Doris Roberts wants you to
uh come over and I think you guys were
maybe 2003 I mean like number one show
on TV so I walk over there across the
aisle way there I go in there I'm
standing back you guys are rehearsing I
see Peter Boyle and Doris and Brad and
Patricia and Ray and the guys there you
know you got you and everybody there and
I'm just standing there watching you
know and and I'm just like kind of like
like this and then the break and I go
talk to Doris and when I go back I say
to my cast I said
I just saw the Chicago Bulls uh practice
like I said these they're so good like
whatever championship team I think at
that time the Bulls were Champion I said
I just saw the best team work out as I
stood to the side of the out of the way
oh that's so nice it really it really
was you guys I made a really great job
thank you but I mean I came back a
different person and I told them
that we approached it like we were we
were a team and we were going to be good
every week and it helped it helped Ted
Danson helped me because he said you
have to maintain the attitude of
gratitude and then when I saw you guys I
said
they're in stage five
doing incredible things
now we're going to be over here and do
incredible things oh thank you man I I
tell you that that thing we said at the
very beginning about learning to
appreciate life as you're living it I
never took that
success that love that luck for granted
I I would I would start we'd have a show
and then the next day we'd have the
table reading right where we all gather
now with the new script yes and I would
thank everybody for the Fantastic show
last night and I would say I got to tell
you something we're not the lucky people
we're the very very very lucky people
wow
did you say did you say that
every day every time I just felt it you
know I just felt you know I think
blessed might be overused but that
really felt that way when
um when the show uh came to an end nine
Seasons how many episodes was that was
it close to 200 210 210 episodes wow
you guys taped on Friday nights
uh I think so yeah the last Thursday the
last show did you guys tape on Saturday
because was Rahab been a difficult time
to end the show
not at all what happened was
uh Patty Heaton got sick oh
on show night yes he lost her voice okay
it was wild I mean
the last taping people are coming from
around the country some people travel
from different countries to come and see
the last taping of Raymond wow and we
had to we had to send them home
because she was sick and then we tried
one more time
and and it's still she still couldn't do
it and finally we said you know let's
just take a whole week off and we did
and when we came back I think whenever
we could and it was just uh
I forget what kind of audience we got we
did get an audience but it wasn't the
same
um but it's still we were happy yeah no
of course and and when it ended did you
go through was it very was it difficult
for you Phil to have it end
to be honest I was so exhausted yeah
you know like you're ready for these
things to end the hardest part is not
saying goodbye to the show it's saying
goodbye to your friends there you go
that's yeah that's very true sure oh
that's very true right yes but you know
the writers and I especially we stayed
friends to this day this is we're
talking about 20 25 years now yeah and
we go out to dinner all the time and Ray
is one of my best friends we go on
vacation our families grew up together
yeah and their friends the wives are
friends so we go on vacation every year
we go to Mexico every year at Christmas
yep yeah and you don't golf too you
don't golf do you
I'm not crazy no yeah not like Ray Ray
I think life is frustrating enough what
are you golfing for here
so so
um in in this what are we going to see
in the season that's that's uh that
we're presenting here the new season
I'm so excited for you to see it it's uh
Croatia have you ever been to Croatia
man that's a beautiful place it's it's
right across the Adriatic Sea from Italy
and it's a lot like Italy I hear I hear
Croatia's incredible
it is incredible it's where Western
meets Eastern Europe it's spectacular
there's a ton of History beautiful
castles and stuff and then these these
great Islands
I mean it's it's truly fantastic and
then I did a few American cities because
we were shooting during covet so some of
the foreign countries were a little more
difficult to get to we still got to
Santiago Chile have you been there no
so we did that that was fantastic and
then we went to uh Washington Texas
Nashville Tennessee and Philadelphia
Pennsylvania barbecue so what so what
are what are we doing different than
what the rest of the world is doing
are we are we so much about what we can
eat or what we can eat I feel I feel
like the rest of the world is more about
what they what they love to eat and
we're about I mean I went to Amsterdam
and we were ordering lunch and somebody
was saying behind us what is that cooked
in and how is that presented and does it
have this and they have that and just
look back and they're Americans
everybody that had an issue with the way
food was being presented was America
I'll be honest with you when I'm
especially when I'm on vacation I mean
I'm not that way anyway but when I'm on
vacation somewhere that's the last thing
I'm thinking about right right yeah to
be fair yeah to be fair some people have
health issues and they have to ask right
but
uh if you're just being picky that you
got to throw that away on me but also
but also if you if you're not being
picky and if you're doing it because you
know you're watching your weight people
should go on vacation and go man people
come back to work and say how was your
vacation [ __ ] I gained 11 pounds on
vacation it's like I couldn't stop
eating but that's what vacation was but
I think in in how we live when it when
we're going to wrap it up and our life
is over you're not going to think about
the the things that you you're gonna
think about the things that you [ __ ]
love that you [ __ ] bypassed because
of you know the dog cholesterol or I
mean I think there's still ways to eat
without having to go someplace these
guys that I grew up with to go eat with
these guys everything is a a [ __ ] and
this guy can't eat that and then you're
just like hey man you know what man I
don't even think I want to eat with you
guys again because it's just like I
think at some point it can't be that
you take the fun out of it right it's
like explaining a joke yes explain it
leave it alone
that's exactly why I want to be cremated
so people don't have to carry my fat ass
once I'm dead
there it is maybe your ashes are way
more than anybody else
or paw bears for that and and uh um
do you eat on a schedule what do you
what do you like to have for breakfast
oh oh I love eggs my Dad loved eggs too
he would have like two or three eggs
every day and the doctors are saying she
you know so many eggs he eat eggs till
he passed away at 96. wow man God bless
you protein uh pancakes french toast are
your pancakes or french toast
uh I like both but I I tend towards eggs
I mean I'm a huge breakfast burrito man
I love it I had it today yeah breakfast
burritos and we live in the land of
Clinton do you make them you get them
what's your favorite breakfast burrito
antenna breakfast burrito you know what
I'm a little old school I like Alberto's
with the french fries in there they
throw everything in there you could
taste the grill with that I don't know
it's a Norwalk you could taste the grill
from the night before you could taste a
little crumbs that left on there if
you're lucky you might get a curly fryer
or asada a little piece of asada but
it's a sense do you know who West Avila
is yes you know Bill esparz is a mutual
friend of ours and yes and Bill uh he he
took me to that place and eat the most
amazing weird tacos I've ever had
well now he has a new place downtown in
Chinatown it's called The Angry Egret
the angry Egret like the bird the egret
and he's got some he's got some killer
killer uh burritos and tacos and what do
you like your man tomorrow morning let's
go let's go
I make my own everybody's known me for
years since my kids were going to High
School breakfast burritos and Ahmed
Papas huevos bacon sausage whatever and
for me there's got to be some chili in
there either my own my own green chili
what about that again
my mine is well there's a lot of them
but
um potato beans bacon egg or chorizo
potato chorizo eggs and potatoes almost
said you like chorizo and and I do I do
and Farmer John uh lean sausage with
eggs and corn tortillas hey Phil you're
the rules man you're the reason I uh I
travel man uh watching a show it's also
the reason why it needs an extension in
the belt that is true
but I went to and I've done my job you
did you know I have a I have interest in
a belt company oh you should I went to a
Japan and uh you're one of the reasons I
went to Japan I wanted to you know just
go out there and I want to do the the
Phil Rosenthal way just go and eat my
way to see what I find and you know what
the most beautiful thing I've learned
from you is how to create a sense memory
of your trips and I think it was the
episode where you go back to Italy when
you went there with your wife when you
guys were first together and that scene
where you eat gelato and you start
tearing up man yeah I started tearing up
just watching you tear up and I'm like
why am I crying but then I actually went
to go get gelato that night and and uh
that's one thing it's like you opened up
that other part of me that eating this
way is actually eating healthier than
the way I was used to eating because I
would just eat whatever you make me feel
so good thank you thank you that episode
that you're talking about was on the PBS
series yes that was called I'll have
what Phil's having I love that that's
where I first saw in Italy is maybe he
was 50 pounds lighter before he watched
that show yeah
but it's a beautiful episode but Phil it
has those episodes are now available for
people on YouTube yeah the company
bought them and put them on they should
watch all that you can see so in the
sense what music does to people food
does to people
that's right when you hear a song or you
or you taste that why were you emotional
uh on that film
when something it you know you sometimes
you can well up because you hear a
beautiful song yeah and sometimes
something just tastes so magnificent it
catches you yeah it's very rare but it
does happen now to be fair
that particular gelato was made right in
front of me by his sweet lady who
spoon-fed it to me in my mouth right
like like your mom would do it and she
was so sweet and the food was so fresh
like you would never get it that way
right out of the thing she literally
just made it wow put it in my mouth and
the whole thing being in Italy meeting
up
stranger who treats you with such
kindness the gelato itself all those
things put together
I it was so good I gave her a kiss on
the cheek I remember that and she kissed
me back
and that all those things combined to
make me uh emotional you know you know
uh when I went to Italy there was a
there was a man who was making uh art
from Mosaic Mosaic piece he would break
up pieces and and we bought a wonderful
piece of art that he made of the church
where his shop was and when we went in
there it says old guy it's got the one
lens he's doing things breaking a little
pieces just everything perfect and and
he said that his kids had no desire to
follow in his footsteps and his great
grandfather had and his grandfather and
his father and him yes and that he was
crying
knowing that that his children had other
interests and not
a hundred plus years of of creating this
incredible art
and I hope that in in things that people
find that are familiar to their family
and that are inherently passed along
genetically that somehow we don't lose
our way and become this kind of middle
of the road oh I don't eat that I can't
do this so that that doesn't interest me
type thing where we start to lose the
things that when people came to this
country they survived on those on those
skills
well yeah I mean you're talking about
keeping Traditions alive and cultures
alive I've met people like this even in
Italy where they make beautiful
Craftsman things and they say this is
the I'm the last of them yeah you know
it's sad right yeah even everything ends
doesn't it everything in restaurants too
where I place my clothes and you know
the guys I got you know and if they just
reopened again they would be better than
than it was you know like we lose I know
yeah you lose the food and I think
that's what I love about your show is
that you're making people try these
dishes at home and look them up and
you're creating New Traditions I mean I
know you create new jerseys in my family
where now we want to know how to make
something because we saw Phil do it in
Oaxaca and we saw Phil do it in Mexico
and you know that's uh that's a gift
that you're giving to a lot of people I
would I would say that
people that are listening or watching
however when you come home food is very
personal to people and I would say that
insularity that we eat a certain way and
I would say that if you watch Phil's
show you watch shows challenge your
family to get outside of that realm of
things that you don't eat and start
looking at things that you want to try
you've got it you've got to get outside
your comfort zone a little bit that's
where the fun is and that's where your
life can change your life ain't gonna
change doing the same thing every day
that's right right well you eat steak of
potatoes every day you're not gonna
you're gonna might miss out on something
it could be something you love more than
that right so you gotta try it you gotta
I know everyone can't afford to go
overseas but go to the next town right
call up uh yeah call up a restaurant in
your neighborhood that you never tried
before so look at the menu on your phone
don't be afraid there you go Shake It Up
stop shake it up and uh um I'm ready to
go to Chinatown in the morning let's go
I mean really there you go yeah by the
way you Momo you brought up a good point
about trying out the recipes I thought
you were about to plug my book the book
comes out the same day I'm excited about
your book I already pre-ordered the book
oh somebody fill the book it's got 60
recipes from the show okay that that's
what we need to do I pre-ordered
oh I love you and I will pre-order and
buy and give them as gifts I'll be
awesome great I want to buy 100 books
and I'm gonna give them all as gifts
I was just about to pre-order but
George's gonna buy no I am and and I
think I'm gonna start a book club and
then everybody that tries the recipe
will get together and bring the recipe
over to the house sure you should do
that because it's out of the comfort
zone sure and I have a I have a nice
Kitchen in my house that I don't usually
I live alone but
my house would benefit
from the smell of incredible food
instead of coming home and everybody's
wood but that that when I when my
grandmother we lived in this little
house and I come home from baseball
practice and and you didn't even need to
get to the door halfway up the walk the
drive the walkway you could start to
smell the food and start to feel the
heat inside of that house and that that
was love
if if you're not smelling the food in
your kitchen the only thing that people
smell of is you and those dogs smell
like Papa yeah hey Phil man thank you so
much man and uh we will be with you guys
you were amazing so much and Momo thank
you man because Momo has been talking
about you for years and years I have and
he's your biggest fan I really am Momo
you're keeping it alive I'm trying
keeping it alive congratulations on all
of your success but this is a good one
for you I like the way it feels good on
you man it looks good on you
thank you my friend nice to be here all
right I hope to see you soon again yeah
right on okay great thank you thanks bye
that's the man right there